mit
is maybe unique in the
extent to which its evolution
was thoughtful and thought ahead of time
when you think of a university you think
of a much broader agenda
it's not just engineers it's schools of
science
humanities social sciences when carl
compton arrived at mit in 1930
the shift began compton was brought in
to really boost the role of the sciences
here
and to make them co-equal partners with
engineering
he began to bring to mit first class
scientists
by the time killian became president you
could begin to speak of the institute
as being a science-based university
and by 1970 let's say all the sciences
at mit
were world-class and the humanities were
on the way up
no technical knowledge can outweigh
knowledge of the humanities
in the gaining of which philosophy and
history
walk hand in hand winston churchill
actually came
and gave a talk where basically he said
this institution
should have a school of humanities
the school of humanities arts and social
sciences
was started because the war
had proved that the
implications of science and engineering
went far
beyond the laboratory or even industry
we are proficient at using the tools we
all go after challenging problems
and in doing so we can forget
the human human interaction we can
forget that it's not just
about water purification but it's about
the individuals who are drinking the
purified water
once you develop the water purification
system
it's interesting that as the students
that we admit struggle to
choose which college they want to attend
they're not looking really at other
institutes of technology so much
they're looking at the other world-class
universities
you don't have to sacrifice your
interest in the humanities and the arts
when you come to mit
that in fact you can have it all
you know having programs like the
humanities and social sciences enriches
the educational experience i think it
puts them in a position to go out into
the world and be
literate about politics about society
about cultural affairs
that's very important and i think it's
really a key
dimension to undergraduate education at
mit